Hey
open
yelling oh mama
sounds are commonly available
mr. Connie and then make the other
hello family for my first night for this
burglar
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm a stylist
[Music]
van Weyden
[Music]
what did we know about life after death
[Music]
it seemed like a strange dream
[Music]
[Music]
eventually we learned the rules learned
to find our way
gather the essentials
we learned to survive
the world is comprised of broken
memories and we are as broken and lost
as the world around us
will we be able to gather enough
strength to find her well
will we ever wake up
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
that is London
[Music]
oh yes you're a Georgian leave their
home da making these Ocean Beach on your
territory Calhoun because I knew
Chancellor
boom young Samuel women are in your lair
don't want you playing charwomen gift
ofnow gift of old bless the
righteousness guide my hand against the
darkness
my final stand
Barbara I want to get to know you a
little bit more you have many friends
where by your sister I play your dragons
or whatever if you ask me to code be
hilarious what are you doing
what's at home there's some serious
stuff going down
I find Giants I hunt Giants I killed
Giants cool yeah that's it dark omens
are totally cool
a giant comes in place and takes
everything from you and when it's done
it's like anything that made your life
good wasn't never even there Giants not
real
[Music]
I know that no one likes me I know that
everything I do works crazy
is it real we're gonna save this town
[Music]
there are times where you have to ask
yourself so I want to live my life is a
coward or a warrior
[Music]
[Music]
again but today sanity's okay yes good
as indeed it is a toad
[Music]
Oh
oh yeah hi hi I'm Mike I'd never really
actively whoever I thought to be pretty
cool you really really want to be a part
of your movie bright it's just a great
film and reminds me a lot of alienation
I love right if you guys think a sequel
I really hope that you can include me in
it I can do some action could be Joel
Edgerton stand-in feel part of the
creative process even I can play dead
Will Smith oh wow Your Honor honestly
she just work was Will Smith that would
make my life trying to get demons of
bottom again turn to what piece eat your
body receipt to CSUN opponent so
properly unleashing the new dog if you
guys play Shadowrun we could play
together
I mean ashen nor Mena fellow
Dharmakara
through beta again featured Samanas that
to regarding Eleonora that don't obey it
scan the pillock as each image
[Music]
and
[Music]
it ain't naughty is order of attention
Boca Grande long-range
[Music]
I mean for Jenna
[Music]
close your eyes see with mine you are a
top student but look at you now you
can't keep using your father's
disappearance as an excuse to act out is
that his work well what's it about their
dad he wanted to touch the Stars imagine
that the aunt here wants to get to her
other hand as quickest option is to walk
across the street but it turns out a
straight line is not the shortest
distance between two points
not if you use fifth dimension it's
outside of the rules we know as time and
space aunt arrives my hand instantaneous
so you fall the space more likely
wrinkle it
[Music]
we heard a cry out in the universe we
believe he is and we're here to help you
find it we are in search of warriors
warriors who serve the good and the
light of the universe you're kidding
do I look like I'm kidding a little I'm
not I'm not your father's trapped by an
evil energy it's too strong for our
light and the only one who can stop it
is you be a warrior
my glove is always there even if you
can't see
[Music]
I trust you
[Music]
I am someone who wakes up in a different
body every day always someone my age
never the same person twice and I have
absolutely no control over any of it
it's not possible it is every day of
your life you've just woken up and just
try to live that day for that person why
are you doing this day we met I felt
something I've never felt before
[Music]
I'm in love with someone who wakes up in
a different body every day always the
same age never the same person tonight
think about what happens if you and I
stay together we can make it work I want
to believe that
[Music]
what will happen to your life if I'm the
person in the world that you're closest
to
you know I thought you'd left left I'd
never leave I do that every day
[Music]
Christmasy time mystery
[Music]
expectations who knows what might happen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
time has come it's probably the hardest
thing that I've ever worked on I'd think
of it as sort of a work of art it's
something hundreds of people created
it's a wonderful texture and depth to
this world it was the most work it was
the most difficult but it was the most
fun it was the most rewarding and of all
projects it's the one that I'm the most
proud of
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you